ich habe mich auch gerade was passiert
einem nicht wenn irgendein anderer
youtuber jetzt mein video sie was was
denken die sich so die müssen sich ja
denken
dieser typ da von dem ich dachte er wäre
eigentlich häufigsten ordnung setzt sich
dahin und bartel von hergiswil mädchen
service und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ich bin euer slk und heute
bringe wieder ein bisschen abwechslung
in die bude
denn ich wurde schon mal für eine
million mal gefragt ob ich eine freundin
habe ob ich eventuell in der beziehung
mit dem pferd bin zweiter sofort und
deswegen ring wir heute mal klarheit in
dieses ganze thema ja liebe pipapo was
ist los mit dem was geht bei dem ab in
seinem kopf haben wir nämlich ein quiz
gefunden auf test.de das heißt bist du
verliebt bist du verliebt
erstellt von nina abdecken so mancher
company na hat ist man sich anmelden
man kann ja nicht einmal so viel action
durchziehen okay leute wir fangen jetzt
einfach mal an mit frage nummer eins
woher kennst du ihn der steht beides das
stimmt beides sowohl weiblich und
männlich ok woher kennst du ihn also
leute ich möchte vorweg schicken das
jetzt nicht unbedingt sicher bin ob ein
mein schwarm ähnliches das kann ich
nicht mit letzter bestimmtheit sagen
und man muss ja wirklich vorsichtig sein
an dem was ein gewisser märkten
abgezogen hat bezüglich äußerungen die
irgendwie es touren fall nicht ausgelegt
werden können auf youtube können wir ihn
gefragt ich sie ersetzen man woher kenne
ich sie bekanntschaft schule straße am
straßenstrich wie die gänge
behelfsstraße für eine aussage von die
bekanntschaft
bekanntschaft ist einfach ein synonym
für jemanden kennen woher kennst du ihn
ja ich kenne ihn dadurch dass ich ihn
kenne ich kenne ihn der richter dass er
mir bekannt ist und an schulklassen aber
dann beim straße weil so viele leute
einfach ihren ihren schwarm auf der
straße kennen lernen ja habt ihr schon
mal ein schwamm auf der straße kennen
gelernt falls ja dann würde ich ihnen
immer genau vor allem was er da gemacht
habe denn vielleicht warteten straßen
krimineller ja ok alles klar
ich gehe nicht mehr zur schule gehen wir
auf die straße
seid ihr gut befreundet eigentlich nicht
so befreundet punkt dass er einmal für
straße gesehen
ich sage jetzt einfach mal ihn ja ich
fürchte jetzt keine keine schwulen
feldweg zwischen mir und diesen selbst
amtierte straße getroffen habe okay
leute bitte keine fan fiction hat er
eine freundin ich weiß es aber nicht ich
habe ihn einmal für straße gesehen
wohlgemerkt wird es ist ja gerade ob wir
verliebt sind ja also ich fühle mich
schon ziemlich verliebt ich habe was
machen was ist das eigentlich gerade für
ein video
aber leute ich hab's verschenkt ich
wollte das eigentlich am anfang des
videos sagen ich möchte einfach mal
danke sagen für jeden der sich diese
videos immer anschaut so jeden tag
ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so
sehr warum leute meine videos schauen
aber umso dankbarer bin ich für jeden
der sich das anschauen wie cool findet
dankeschön an dich da draußen ein
bisschen zu zeigen dass ich auch dass
ich wirklich dankbar dafür bin dass ich
auch mal sage mal gesagt zu haben für
stalking scheiß dem match alter möchte
ich euch die gelegenheit geben heute
einfach mal alles rein zu schauen was
ich an diesem kanal hier nervt was nervt
ihrem kanal was würdet ihr verändern
spam das einfach nach unten in die
kommentare und wenn ihr irgendwas eine
andere geschrieben hat so zum beispiel
ok dazu dass und das nervt mich es gibt
eine beschissene frisur
ja und ich denke es euch auch dann
leitet den kommentar hoch und falls es
noch nicht da steht hat selbst ein
kommentar mit dem gedanken so ich möchte
einfach ein bisschen euer feedback
einbauen bestätigt diesmal also ich bin
fünf mal sehr gespannt und ich checke
die kommentare okay da machen weiter wie
lange griffs stunde solchen wächst
drei bis vier jahre hier leute es
handelt sich hier immerhin ein
männliches wesen was ich vor drei bis
vier jahren auf der straße getroffen
habe einmal gesehen aber ich bin in
dieses wesen da bin ich verliebt wir
wissen es nicht wirtschaften chips sieht
er gut aus alter richtig spread auf
jeden fall
wieso magst du ihn wieso sollte man
testen ob ihnen jemand verliebt ist in
dem man nicht mag aber charakter auf
jeden fall
wie ist dein charakter wir müssen jetzt
auch immer gerade meinen kopf sehen
können in meinem kopf so lustig süß net
lebensfroh sagen einfach mal bis da ein
mädchenschwarm ich sollte nicht nachts
um halb zwei videos aufnehmen ich hoffe
es ist unterhaltsam
falls nicht schreibt einen kommentar mit
radiergummi radiergummi kommentare
unterhaltsam ist okay ist ein
mädchenschwarm glaubt das nicht
ich glaube nicht ich glaube dass
bienenschwarm hast du schon was mit ihm
unternommen
leider nein nur einmal gesehen vor vier
jahren leider
ich habe mich auch gerade was passiert
eigentlich wenn irgendein anderer
youtuber jetzt um ein video sieht man
also ich glaube ein paar leute die
aktion meine videos anschauen zum
beispiel wenn luca was macht sich so die
müssen sich ja denken dieser tief da von
dem ich dachte er wäre eigentlich
halbwegs in ordnung setzt sich dahin und
brachte die vier mädchen einfach nur
what the [ __ ] diese auch von brenntag
allein deswegen muss ich das hochladen
für euch ja okay leute seitdem bereits
frage 10
seid ihr bereit für die alles
entscheidende und letzte frage und dann
natürlich das ergebnis zu guter letzt
glaubst du dass du dich auch mag
ich kenne jetzt mal erzählen dass diese
personen profi angetroffen haben auf der
straße einmal gesehen aber ich glaube da
mag ich auch ich glaube dirk schoppmann
youtube videos ganz ehrlich ich glaube
dass auch weil es so draußen beschreibt
einen kommentar und schreibt ein
das ist zu viel
dre zu sein ich finde es witzig aber
eigentlich darf man sowas nicht hoch
werden und drehen die welt mir sitzt zu
hause
hier kommt der schule nach hause nächste
ei ascend neues video hochgeladen
schau mal ein wasser gemacht hat und
euer gesicht ist doch weil ich einfach
die verstörung so scheiße an diesem
video mache also ich finde ich muss dazu
sagen dass ich einfach gerne scheiß
machen
das muss man wissen über mich ich habe
mich noch nie so gesagt aber ich mache
einfach gerne scheiße einfach nur
scheiße gemacht zu haben nur bereit
dafür zu erfahren ob wir verliebt sind
leute hier draußen der vaarts auch mit
mir und deswegen jetzt auswertung sollte
traumrolle drew barrymore grambow cases
sind wir sind verliebt leute es ist
offiziell
es ist offiziell wie soll ich dieses
video beenden leute ich bin auf jeden
fall sehr gespannt auf eure reaktion wie
gesagt kritik was stellt euch an diesem
channel und in die kommentare und
hochbauten wenn deine idee seht ihr euch
gefällt soll es sich um sehr okay der
kommentar die meisten likes und
ansonsten immer soweit durch für heute
die entschuldigung mich vielmals für
dieses verstörende video aber ich glaube
es auch ein bisschen lustig für euch und
leute zum abschluss dieses videos jede
person die dieses video zeigt erhält
meinen reisepass meinen eigenen
reisepass für jede einzelne person die
das widerlegt das wird wirklich
passieren der reisepass wird in eurem
briefkasten erscheinen ungefähr 45
sekunden hatte man das video gelebt hat
mein reisepass
dann könnt ihr euch jetzt sk ausgeben
haut rein und ja wie gesagt danke fürs
zuschauen
danke dafür dass er die firma
einschaltet